when that was a little guy way back in
the 1980s I loved two things more than
anything else and that was Star Wars and
breakdancing some friends and I figured
out how to combine the two
not all Star Wars figures can do this
first you need is an original three and
three-quarter inch figure and don't go
using a mint-condition Boba Fett's it's
worth like a grand on eBay all you need
to do is get a couple guys with nice
round heads now this the stormtrooper
inhofe battle gear is a good choice get
rid of any weapons you don't need them
this is a dance battle
not a gun class then you take a dime
just one thin dime like so and you kind
of wedge it in between the action
figures legs up here at the top so that
you're flush with the crotch what an
awesome phrase that is and so that
you're pushing the legs out a little bit
so you kind of have this Y shape from
there you find a nice flat surface you
put the action figure on its head yeah
grab it on either side try to try to get
it on its arm so you have some leverage
and give it a good twirl like a top try
to use some force if you know what I
mean there you go sweet head straight